so I was reading today and came across
couple interesting articles Eric Shawn
field who by the way I love a great
writer for TechCrunch former editor
large business two point oh my favorite
magazine I wrote an article about google
stock crashing Globe and Mail which I
was in mob and Canada the big like New
York Times type paper and Canada writing
about how google's stock is soft
obviously the whole market stomping but
both of them pointed and globe mail said
it was dead Eric kind of pointed to a
softening a softening and advertising in
the Google world in the online space and
I actually kind of haven't answered that
with the economy getting much softer um
and people trying to tighten up layoffs
tighten their advertising budget even
though that's something you should never
tighten um I actually have an answer to
the people that think that people are
going to drop and people like Google are
going to struggle here's my answer ah no
just like Costco and Walmart becomes
stars in this kind of economy just like
wine library really this is where we
start shining because of our pricing
Google and other social media websites
are going to pick up business do you
know why because of something called roi
do you know why cuz of ROI do you know
why cuz roi that's a little bit of light
hey you down with OPP yeah you know me
that's my thing do you know why roi the
return on the investment do you know
who's in trouble with this economy the
radio you know houses in trouble
magazines are in trouble my friends
magazines are in trouble because Gucci
buying this ad in The New York Magazine
for fifty sixty eighty thousand dollars
is climb city in 2008 you think there's
ROI on this there's not I promise you
you know I loses the newspaper you think
it's smart to buy this at Macy's I don't
I think you get a twitter account and
you start interacting with your
community get 30 interns and you make
much more roi now is the whole
on the internet shopping buying building
ring of course not but if you don't
realize that the eyeballs are way down
way down on newspaper you know what you
want to see something cool come on let's
zoom in over here we have 125 people
watching me on ustream how did you read
the newspaper every day go give me a yes
no muck in here good matos that's a good
yes zoom in your mot here we go no no no
no no hell no no no no yes yes no no I
don't know no no no no yes no no
newspaper ? no no no no no no yes I
spent some coin today no no no some no
yes the bottom line is and again I'm not
a clown I you know I know what you guys
are gonna say right now these are people
on ustream in the middle day there's
social media savvy their computer savvy
of course they are but what you have to
understand is the world's changing my
mom is spending a crapload of time now
on the internet you know what I was
gonna lose this mod down here this is
who's gonna lose the television the
television is going to lose because
these are places where you are paying
Abba noxious pricing for your
advertising dollars however in social
media places like facebook and google
when Twitter gets smart and starts
monetizing or like a sign like viddler
that has little boxes or YouTube or
other places anything subject matters
that have to do with you for example
gucci would be far better off going to
every you know watch blog and buying ads
there because not only are the prices on
the ROI cpmc mios whatever I don't care
CTR whatever CT season you use the value
they get on the back end is so much
higher and here's a better one my
friends they can track it Pepsi Green
Mountain Coffee coca-cola Gillette you
guys you know I talk to a lot of you
marketing guys behind the scenes now
talking to all the brands out there you
can track this you don't have to guess
with this mint you can track it and
there's so many long tail places all
these little video bloggers all these
bloggers where you get so much much much
more on your ROI and you know what I'm
confident that there's a lot of people
in these companies right now that wreck
Isis and are going into the fourth
quarter realizing if they haven't meet
the buys already and a lot of people
have and are realizing so looking for or
early on I'm seeing even more recurrence
I think realizing that this is the new
space to spend money on because the
costs are much lower and you get true
value on your return on your investment
people going to be gravitating to places
like Google I for example from the Wine
Library side have not bought any
billboards for this fourth quarter like
I've been doing and I'm not going to be
buying any star-ledger abs or any
magazine ads I just today bumped up my
google advertising this is what made me
do it I bumped up our Google advertising
you know Adsense and I see all these
articles I don't know i mean the stock's
gonna be down because the whole markets
down but i don't see companies going
away from online marketing and when they
start embracing social media marketing
it's really gonna explode guys it's a
ticking time bomb it's just this for
these guys I mean I love a lot of people
in the newspaper and magazine business
and tell me I'm telling you and Alyssa
that's a decade from now but see you
next time